và bất đi chỉ lược chiếc cuộc kỳ chương cấp.
Từ khi ra mắt, anh ra, mắt chiếc khoan,
a gược nôn tập trung theo đổi phân khúc nhà ở chung cấp tại thành của chiming và khu cuộc sắp dành.
Công thiết thích thực mẹn ấy mở giống quyết dất,
yêu tiên các dự án sạch của hợp phát triển sẽ phẩm vừa tối tiền, tư răng chỉ khai nhé.
Mình kệ đó để đa giọng, mình muốn,
anh ra cũng tăng kêu vừa tá hơi các tổ chức,
quy đổi từ nước ngoài như anh nhật, hạn.
Công sự đông hành của các ngân hàng, đối táp trong bằng ngoài nước.
Công trong bị tự íc của chội sợ với phân khúc như hồ bơi vô cờ,
sân tên yết, phòng tập vô rả lập.
Công thiết khốn chú trong công táp bảo hành,
bảo chi cắt thiết bị, kích cấu và hệ tổng toàn nhà nhằm đảm bảo quy lợi của cư dân.
Bởi thế chi, sân phẩm sau tốt hơn sân phẩm trước,
các dự án của án ra là cái quả của một quả trình thiết kế và sế dự chi chủ.
Công thiết thực kiến cho giám mắt sự án đợ gió rối vừa sai tại khu đông thành của chiming trong tháng 8 năm,
anh ấy khu chăm ai mới làm.
Mời giống các kênh phân phẩm phôi cho bạn nhìn con hộ đồ gió rối vừa sai.